jeudi 10 mars lors de la journée des
droits des femmes bien entendu une
chanteuse russe anastasia wisches keynes
qui a participé à un concert en sibérie
alors tout se passait bien et ça se
passait tellement bien qu'elle a voulu
se rapprocher du public
sauf qu'elle s'est un peu trop approché
regardait nous a fait ce qu'on appelle
une shy'm
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu as fait tes sens pourrait céder
sur les bases d'un peuple et battre la
peau sans rigoler malgré cet accident
donc à la route elle a tenu à terminer
sa chanson bravo elle le droit des
femmes donc bravo à une gros big up
[Applaudissements]
voilà qu'on embrasse alors et après le
concert la chanteuse a tout de même été
emmené à l'hôpital pour soigner une
fracture du pied vous est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu une grosse honte en public
vraiment une honte de fourmies voilà il
vous est arrivé au coib live à l'époque
de tf1 grosse soirée y avait vraiment
tout le métier ça il y avait vraiment
voilà de tous les animateurs les pontes
etc et je m'étais vraiment à prêter
j'étais très soulagé j'avais fait en
sorte d'être jolie etc et il y avait un
jour jolidon assez gentil mais pas
besoin
c'est très gentil que s'il vous arrive
pas je vois il y avait un immense
escalier donc évidemment il y avait des
photographes avaient le photocall etc
sauf que j'ai je suis arrivé et je me
suis vautré dans votre élan dans une
merde mais vraiment j'ai dévalé
l'escalier devant tout le monde avec les
photographes qui devront baisser leur
leur appareil pour pas tu vois qu'ils
étaient plutôt gentil mais donc je me
suis relevé en mode m'a même pas mal non
en fait ça c'était tout en haut il est
horrible et après on me dit on m'a dit
mais il faut quand même aller faire les
photos photocall donc là tu vas faire
ton photocall tu es quand même école un
peu gêné de dutoit donc de travail était
alors que tu viens de te vautré comme
une grosse merde donc voilà et tout cela
forme a dit ça va ça va avec un r c'est
vrai qu'ils ont fait de moi chez moi la
plus grosse honte de ma vie je sais pas
si vous voulez déjà raconté je ne met
pas brown
c'est encore une histoire de toilette
ah non c'est du père et je vous le dit
c'est encore une histoire de toi et tu
sais pas s'il voulait raconter je suis
au ski avec un pote
ouais on fait les beaux gosses mons à
skis ça fait des gosses beau tout ça
quand tout à coup on va au restaurant
d'altitude
mais là bon c'est un kif et la frère je
sens mon frère que là elle a fondu je
suis très très mal a fondu
elle n'est pas dans mon assiette aller
dans mon slip et je peux vous dire les
mecs je sens que ça va très très mal se
terminer
on est pratiquement on est en train de
manger tranquille là je sens frère que
je suis très mal
maintenant j'ai les chaussures de ski je
suis comme as je me lève maintenant tu
connais aussi la reille d'annoncer une
seule étape her daughter de casser la
tête était comme à l'ailé la vie jeté
l'émoi les toilettes en bas de
l'escalier et la sphère gens nous ont
offert les pendra sera mais on va sera
totale c'est que c'est en bas d'un
escalier
l'espagne et les comédiens l'a35 marché
là de l'eau partout pour dire tu y vas
prendre aucun risque et moi frère c'est
pas que le boeing il en bout de piste
varrault décoller les frérots je suis
pas bien du tout suite au match nul ici
nous a jugé comme un et là je descends
les escaliers gratte savez sur les idées
sauriez sky et grâce et la ferait le
moins au milieu des escaliers moindre
effort sa part ça s'arrête
1 pourquoi il ya une queue de castor
[Rires]
doublé et l'horaire personnes qui
doivent aller aux toilettes alors écoute
moi bien moi je me dis je suis en classe
donc qu'est ce que je fais je passe sur
la gauche frère et là je vais chez les
meufs les meufs frères pareil une
dizaine de bacs jaunes mais un peu moins
mais une dizaine de personnes qu attend
j'attends j'attends et la phrase je vois
que derrière moi la queue elle se
remplit
c'est à dire qu'on dirait pas là que
pointent les toilettes on dirait qu'ils
croyaient qu'il fallait prendre les
toilettes pour lotir fait un truc de ouf
et la frère arrive mon tour maintenant
moi ça fait vingt minutes nous attend et
frère le gramme
pas de papier c'est que je me mets
cammas est tellement que je suis pressé
vrai nom je fais sur toute la cuvette
or mes pairs c'est robert jean de la
dette
c'était pas des négos chocolat
non mais je vous dis de partout ses
frères vivent et sortir et qui a une
quinzaine de mars
il en savoir les âges étaient chez les
hommes et deux que j'ai fait une erreur
et déjà neuf années de misère il
attendait avait nettoyé attendez
attendez ban mêlée mais qu'est ce que
j'ai fait moi sur la vie de ma mère tu
te bats qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai mis
le couvert comme ça et tu voulais qu'il
écoute moi bien un verre sur la tête de
ma mère
après je suis cammas jeu sort des
toilettes je bois je sors je vois mes 15
9 14 ans dit je mets des lunettes de
soleil maintenant je vois pas pourquoi
c'est pas non plus le moral n'y était
jamais débuté accent sur la haie pour
cette soirée faire je vais commencer
avec des après skis je courais l'a donc
comment quand je suis au milieu des
escaliers j'entends café
sa patrie la buba c'est la même chose
pour faire plus jamais revu dans la
station sol
[Applaudissements]